russian president vladimir putin's first
face-to-face meeting with a nato leader
since russia's invasion of ukraine in
february putin and turkish president
recep tayyip erdogan were in iran's
capital tehran to discuss a unbacked
proposal to resume exports of ukrainian
grain through the black sea to help ease
the global food crisis
i want to thank you for your efforts in
mediation providing a forum for
negotiation on food problems on the
problem of grain export by the black sea
we moved forward under your mediation
not all the problems have been resolved
yet but it's already good that there is
a movement
on his second international trip since
the start of the war in ukraine putin
also met iranian president ibrahim raisi
who hosted the trilateral summit
both russia and iran are among the most
sanctioned countries in the world and
the two nations are now seeking to boost
economic cooperation
this level of business and trade between
the two countries is definitely not
enough considering the existing
capacities and it can go to a higher
level we think we can reach 30 billion
dollars which is three times more than
the current number
just before putin's visit russian energy
giant gazprom and iran's national oil
company signed a memorandum of
understanding worth 40 billion dollars
to develop a gas field around kish
island in the gulf
this summit is a part of astana format a
mechanism that was established five
years ago between russia turkey and iran
to end the 11 year war in syria
while russia and iran are the main
backers of the syrian government led by
bashar al-assad turkey has effectively
supported the syrian opposition
since 2016 turkey has also launched
three major military operations inside
syria against kurdish armed group ypg
and isis
and ankara says preparations are now on
the way to conduct a fourth operation
into syria to create a 30 kilometer deep
security zone a plan that both russia
and iran oppose
but the turkish president did not back
down
milligrams
we are determined to drive out the
centers of evil from syria that threaten
our national security
as astana guarantors our expectation
from the russian federation and iran is
to support turkey in this fight
despite this all three presidents said
the astana peace process has been
effective in setting up a foundation for
peace in syria
russia has withdrawn most of his forces
from syria after the war began in
ukraine now syria is increasingly
becoming a source of tension between
turkey and iran as they both have a
significant military presence in the
country the next round of the trilateral
summit under astana format will be held
in moscow but the fragile balance
between these three countries could
possibly be disturbed in case of a
military operation into syria unless
they can find a diplomatic solution to
the crisis rasul sardar al-jazeera terra